pues aunque el boceto publicado Hace
unas horas no hace ninguna mención
específica al tema al parecer se habría
llegado a un acuerdo para crear este
famoso fondo que pague por las pérdidas
y daños irreparables derivados de la
climática aunque aún no está por
confirmar que países se beneficiarían se
dice que serían los países vulnerables
en desarrollo no sabemos Qué significa
esto realmente nos especifica Cuáles
serían esos países ni tampoco se sabe
cómo se financiará Es decir de dónde
saldrá el dinero porque la Unión Europea
quería que por ejemplo países con
fuertes economías como China y Arabia
Saudita aunque se consideran países en
desarrollo estarán incluidos estén
incluidos no se sabe Aún si esto se
habrá decidido en este acuerdo alcanzado
tampoco se sabe si habrá fondos
provenientes del sector privado por
ejemplo impuestos a las grandes
compañías por ejemplo aéreas o de
transporte marítico que son marítimo que
son grandes contaminantes aún hay muchos
detalles por definir detalles que
saldrán de la plenaria que se
desarrollará a lo largo de la tarde aquí
en Egipto por otro lado en el texto
publicado como bien decía Hace unas
horas no hay muchos apartados que no
tienen ninguna novedad con respecto al
texto de Glasgow del año pasado de la
Cope 26 Como por ejemplo no hay mención
a la inclusión de todos los combustibles
fósiles para su reducción progresiva y
así avanzar en la mitigación es decir en
la reducción de emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero por ahora solo
aparece en ese texto el carbón